this is two more Hussein standing in for
freelance reviewer Richard weakling
the dark Sider series has always worn
its inspirations on its sleeve but at
least there was a sense of focus and
consistent design omnipresent in all of
its moving parts those first two games
may have been derivative but they took
concepts and built on them in fun and
engaging ways that elevated their strong
points Darksiders 3 is the antithesis of
this approach feeling muddled and
unfocused with an uneven design that
trickles down and negatively affects
each of its disparate systems what
pathetic Satan he's brought upon
yourself after both war and death had
their fun in Darksiders three's
predecessors it's now the turn of the
perpetually angry fury fury wills a
bladed whip known as the Bob's of scorn
which offers both decent range and a
satisfying feedback of meaty hits once
you're up close and personal in an
enemy's face throughout the game you'll
acquire hollows that grant unique
secondary weapons and they open up your
traversal options with different
elemental effects
combos are relatively easy to execute
with one button dedicated to primary
attacks and another to those
aforementioned secondary strikes button
mashing is enough to get you through
most encounters but mixing in slight
delays between button presses will allow
you to pull off air combos and other
similarly stylish moves it certainly
looks the part of a flamboyant action
game but these flashy combos are only
really feasible against weaker enemies
dockside history has taken some clear
inspiration from Dark Souls so Furies
low survivability forces you to approach
combat in a way that belies its
exuberant combos enemies are fast and
hit hard and are regularly found in
groups with no stamina meter to speak of
there's an emphasis on dodging and
keeping out of danger that does deviate
from Dark Souls a stringent use of
energy management each perfectly timed
dodge is rewarded with a slow-motion
flourish and the chance to count with a
powerful arcane attack and most clashes
are built around Fury's ability to weave
out of the way of incoming sword slashes
and ravenous claws there's a good
variety of enemy types to reading their
attack patterns and knowing when to
evade is paramount to defeating almost
every enemy you can't simply banish with
a single combo but Darksiders 3 never
leans into this considered approach to
combat enough and out of place vestiges
of its flashy counterpoint regularly
caused frustration as it seems to split
between wanting to be two very different
types of games you may have air juggles
and various strings of deadly moves at
your disposal but you're often forced to
settle for safe combos because anything
else would leave you wide open to a
devastating attack then there's the way
you'd lock on to enemies this was
clearly designed with one-on-one battles
in mind and certainly doesn't fit in a
game as challenging as this while there
are undoubtedly some tough enemies in
Darksiders free the real difficulty
comes from facing more than one enemy at
a time rather than a singular threat
groups of enemies are intrinsically
tougher due to their numbers and the
unwieldy lock on and a terrible camera
make these fights a lot more challenging
than they otherwise would be the camera
has a tendency to block your view with
walls and any object in the vicinity
which is only exacerbated by the clocks
Truffaut begin vironment that dominate
the majority of the game dying because
you can't see or because switching
targets is too fiddly our constant
annoyance not to mention the number of
times you're hit by an attack from off
screen there's an indicator for incoming
attacks but it's incredibly difficult to
discern in the thick of action and no
such warning exist for projectiles the
oxide is free also strips out a lot of
the RPG elements from its immediate
predecessor killing enemies rewards you
with souls which can also be found
throughout the game world in consumable
clusters each time you reach a
checkpoint you can trade them to a
demonic merchant in order to level up
three attributes health strength and
arcane it's a very simplistic
progression system and while you can
lose souls by dying and must then
retrieve them again there's never any
tension born from the threat of
perishing and losing them all because
you can Bank Souls even if you don't
have enough to level them up weapons can
be upgraded to increase their damage
output and enhancements will augment
your arsenal with buffs but there's no
sense of individuality here and combat
never evolves because all you're doing
is boosting your damage output this is a
problem when combat is all-encompassing
there are some rudimentary puzzles
sprinkled throughout but they're very
few and far in between none of this is
particularly engaging and that goes for
the rare instance of platforming as well
grabbing onto ledges is too
temperamental and docksiders really
lacks a cohesive visual language that
makes some platforming sections more
convoluted than they should be the
apocalyptic wasteland of Earth just
isn't that interesting to traverse
either the interconnected wall is made
up of dilapidated office buildings grimy
subways and flooded industrial areas
each of these locales is enveloped by
muted colors dominated by beige and gray
with only a couple of areas deviating
from this bland design your quest might
revolve around tracking down and killing
the seven deadly sins but the
environments you're in rarely reflect
their diverse personalities which feels
like a squandered opportunity
verticality plays a substantial role in
these environments but there's no sense
of scale when you're regularly confined
to dank corridors in Subway's and caves
it's a shame too because while the bulky
comic book art style of Joe Madureira is
still reflected in the excellent
character design the backdrop for these
larger-than-life beings is this generic
insipid world though I don't want to
humanity is tragically overrated I am
NOT here for them I'm docksiders three
is also rife with constant framerate
issues even on a ps4 Pro on top of
crashes sound glitches and other
technical misgivings - the oxide is free
retrogrades on its predecessors with an
unfocused approach that constantly
clashes with itself there are remnants
of a good game here buried within the
vivacious combos of a combat style this
game doesn't want to embrace
unfortunately it's buried far too deep
to ever Salvage cannot believe I am
guilty of these crimes something is
wrong with the you
be vigilant fury
bosses conspire against us heed my words